Entertainment Tonight co-host Kevin
Frazier back we love having you in the
first hour whenever we're here because
you bring you our mister energy I love
being here but today I feel like you're
on American I honestly I feel like this
is one of the biggest sports days in
American history and you guys are like
you said do I have on a rugby Jersey are
you a rugby Jersey
do you know number eight is one of the
greatest players in American history
like this guy is is hall-of-famer Clint
Dempsey is one of the greatest players
in American history and tonight is one
of the biggest games we must beat Panama
in the hex if we lose we are out we're
out in Panama will clinch do you go into
the World Cup Clint Dempsey's nickname
what what do you mean Clint Dempsey's
nickname yeah
I mean you're so in red white blue is
Clint Dempsey's nickname deuce I mean
okay see no you came at me you came
after me don't come in there like hey
there goes deuce know everybody's like
Clint Dempsey because he's a great
player but here's what I'm saying to you
that's like saying you know Panama
tonight I mean come on man we missed the
World Cup like the ramifications of that
are massive I'm just kidding I like this
you know I need you to get on the pitch
you know you can't count them out though
throughout the records when Panama gets
together I will tell you this today the
Fraser boys will get home and their
jerseys will be folded on the couch and
we'll put them on and we'll have snacks
for the game our neighbors will come
over and will be deep in it because this
is a pivotal moment in American soccer
history and you should be down with why
is it that it feels like there's always
like ten pivotal moments with him USA
soccer every year what aren't their
pivotal moments ever it like was last
night a pivotal moment for the Patriots
yeah if they had lost it would be armed
again today so I mean there that's what
we do in sports we say it's a pivotal
moment in sports but we're told that
this is a big moment for USA soccer well
if you were watching you know it is
because if we miss the World Cup then
you're talking about millions of
eyeballs why are we in the position
where we may miss the World Cup all your
can cleanse me and cleanse me
ask him I mean you know that was I have
an issue with Jurgen Klinsmann that he
didn't help develop our country and he
didn't help develop the talent in our
country and now you know we have some
guys who are getting a little bit older
we have a couple of fabulous young kids
but basically we have a bunch of old
guys hanging tough no I know and I
respect them I love them I love him I
love clint dempsey he may come off the
bench today but you know we still love
and respect them but it's a it's a huge
game we must beat Panama today and by
the way surprise enough I just want to
say that I just want to say that if you
if you notice that you had 68,000 people
first sellout in the Mercedes been dope
in football country in Atlanta was the
football the soccer team see I even go
football but the soccer team they sold
out the new football stadium before
Falcons do who are you I'm just saying
my passion man you gotta have passion
gotta have passionate like I give Paulie
five seconds to soccer time five good
second a week yeah but this is a
different deal tonight man this is the
World Cups on the line brother if we're
not in the World Cup everything changes
like we need this win tonight
like everybody turn the baseball off
tonight and just plop down in front of
that TV and give our guys some love I
hope everybody noir Lando turns out that
Stadium should be rockin if I didn't
have to work today I would be in Orlando
with my boys and we'd be deep in it we'd
be marching we'd be marching to the
stadium who could walk in right now
soccer wise where you would just say oh
my god like bow down Cristiano Cristiano
Ronaldo I mean he he's prediction I mean
listen any too good-looking
you know what he is a beautiful man but
when you're a beautiful man you can back
it up that's all that matters you know
that's the whole thing like they're like
Kris Humphries is a good-looking guy but
his game didn't translate to that you
know what I mean like you got a more of
a messy kind of guy named Neymar well
let me say this
my family is all Barcelona people we've
made the pilgrimage to Barcelona to see
them each day I'm Marissa okay
just helping you with you you know when
I when I said that I was a fan of
Cristiano Ronaldo's my children went in
and took all my Barcelona jerseys out of
my closet and hid them because they said
I was a traitor to the family I was like
what's going on they took my jerseys
away
um so and whenever I go to Europe
whether it's a movie junket or whatever
I make sure that I get in a soccer game
no matter what I am I am at some stadium
watching some team play that's kind of
it
because knowing you at the mothership
you were all about basketball
I what well I'm a basketball guy my
father basketball coach and I love
basketball but I mean soccer you know we
were early adopters my father was an
assistant coach for the Knicks and
because of that the at that time the
Knicks owned the Washington diplomats in
the NASL so back in the day when they
had pain lay and all those guys at the
at the cosmos we would go to those games
the Washington diplomats and Joe Horvath
was the you know the striker for them
and I mean we hated the cosmos there's a
big week in Washington when the cosmos
were coming so I mean get what soccer
man Franz Beckenbauer Beckenbauer Joe
Giorgio Chinaglia yeah oh yeah yeah that
was and and we hated that team I mean
you could say that I felt the way I feel
about the cosmos the way I felt about
the earth days today because they stole
my football team but that's a different
hold I mean there's stuff there's Kevin
Frazier from Entertainment Tonight the
co-host
did your dad coach you um just briefly
and let me just say this when I was a
little kid my dad could not contain
himself with officials like when I was
10 my dad was the guy who was screaming
at the guy who was getting paid $7 to
ref 22 games in the day because he'd
missed a three-second call or because he
called it you know a travel or a foul on
me
there was a problem after a while my mom
was just like you're not coming to the
but can you see any parallel and
obviously it's a different time
different generation with Lavar ball
with his kids you know the modern-day
dad with what he made marketing and
coaching you know let me say this about
levar and I don't know what he's doing
with his youngest son but I wouldn't I
saw I went I went to see them play
because I was like what is this thing
and watching his kids play this year was
one of the worst basketball experiences
of my life because they weren't playing
basketball yeah and what they were doing
was madness them the game I saw they
played modern-day bowl bowl my new bowl
son played on that team and I mean they
were 9 of 63 from the floor his two kids
and they were 9
three taking incredibly stupid shots so
I'm gonna say this to levar right now
because when he got on the AAU circuit
it was a different flavour for young
lamella and for his his youngest and so
I think that he needs to put his kid in
the system and back up for a second and
I know that sounds crazy but you have to
learn how to play basketball and work in
a team environment because no one's that
great well now hold him out of school
Kevin it's listen and now he's gonna be
playing more Street ball and that's the
problem when I would watch and I
remember watching him as a freshman yep
and I saw shots that we would not we
would not be taken out of the game we
would be sent home from the aim of if
somebody takes that shot at the Bristol
why it's a fight when we were you know
you're in the Y and you're like bro I
came here to plane if you're gonna take
those stupid shots I'm leaving Oh or you
just never picked that guy up I was
shocked and even when my nine-year-old
looks at me and says he's taking crazy
shots daddy I mean they that game the
game I saw went into overtime because on
the last possession
he took a shot from nearly half court to
win the game and I was like when the
shot clock winding down and like he
dribbled by he sat on it yeah so what
I'm telling you is I'm telling you and
you know levar can get mad or whatever
but he's killing his kid right now
because he's not playing basketball
right now
Lonzo is a amazing talent and if you go
back and look at that team when Lanza
was playing Lanza was an incredible
talent and he could lift them above
tough situations his youngest could and
wait until you see some UCLA games this
year you're gonna be you're gonna well
the Angelo is not on par with the other
two but what I'm saying is is like and
I'm not being a hey I don't want people
to be like oh you're just getting on in
hating no I'm not hating ly Angelo
should play at Long Beach State and
don't put him at UC that's he's not a
UCLA player and that's what I'm gonna
tell you a kid who shoots turnaround
threes for a living
shouldn't be playing at UCLA and that's
why I never got to UCLA but and so it's
I don't understand it and I get it I get
the hype and they were basically they
did what uh you know what Weston what
Paul Westhead used to do and basically
except at least with what Paul Westhead
and what they were doing they would
cross half cool
these kids don't cross half-court I've
never I've never seen anything like it
I've never seen anything like it
all right take a deep breath here okay
we're gonna take a break we're gonna
regroup
we've talked soccer we talked the ball
family I want you to be an American no
Dan om be an American I mean get behind
our team tonight it's big deal guys you
had a jersey like that for me I'd be
wearing it right and I have 20 I would
have brought one for you I should have
brought one for Lou but I can get you
one don't worry it'll be don't worry
there'll be one votes at Nike babysit
and that's all I'm gonna wear tonight
okay that's it that's all I'm asking and
my shoes and that's it well come back
we'll take a break more with Kevin
Frazier Willie McGinest will join us
coming up a little bit later on and the
mayor of Los Angeles the rock star Eric
Garcetti join us coming up as well ice
coach I've props to him was on a flight
with him and he got he went back and
flew coach I was like you're a baller
but you love you mister player but you
were in first class but he was in coach
yeah we'll be back after this somebody I
bet you yeah I'm flying the colors if
you're watching right now on DirecTV
audience know we're channel 239 Team USA
be an American I am okay Team USA Panama
tonight you know I like to call it
football you may call it soccer but I
call it football
I threw a football out there I slipped
in no I slipped the football in there
but I'm just saying I'm hyped up I mean
you should have woke up with like a
little no but I'm confident are you
confident we'll win yes
what about to Tuesday we have Trinidad
you know that we have to go to but not
Tobago shirt about Aunt May oh it is
yeah I mean they combined tonight's two
teams TNT yeah yeah Trinidad I don't
worry about Tobago makes me really
nervous
poll question for Kevin Frazier here
McLovin okay you get to start a team
with one quarterback who's 23 and under
choices are DeSean there you go he's
proven he's a winner and you have that
defense behind him but I love the way
the kid carries himself the fact that he
took his first paycheck and gave it over
to the hurricane victims I mean he just
he has his head all he has head on
straight
what if Jared Goff beats the Seahawks
this weekend
I mean look Jared Goff as you said he he
didn't play defense last year and Jared
Goff has found his comfort zone and I
think you know he could become a real
star in LA like this could be the thing
that
tells the rams to actually people care
in LA about the Rams and so I get it but
right now Deshawn do you get the feeling
that LeBron is coming here do I get the
feeling when he's touring schools yeah I
mean here's the thing that everybody has
to understand his production company and
that will be the next act for LeBron is
all the things he's doing I mean he you
know they got a 15 million dollar deal
and and they are producing a viable
content for television
LeBron's future is in TV and what he
makes and he'll be an influencer so la
is the perfect place for him and it's a
great place to finish and it's a place
he wants his kids to grow up in he loves
LA but does he have to move out here
while he's still playing and play for
the Lakers why why not I mean listen at
the end of the day what he is done for
Cleveland and Ohio has been amazing and
Dan you know you spend time in Ohio and
you know what it means
with the time that he has spent there
him coming back I mean when he wrote
that letter he came back the first time
he ran out on that court for Cleveland
again if you didn't have tears in your
eyes if you did if it didn't like make
here like give you goose pimples then
you're crazy when they won that
championship and you saw how emotional
he was you could tell that this was
everything like the fact that also he is
sending 1,000 kids in the Akron area to
college the amount of that he has put
back in as a just as a philanthropist
the things he's done for that Arian will
always do he's given so no I also think
they the Lakers are the final act to be
able to do something that nobody else
has done so if you'd bring a title to
Miami Cleveland and you did this with
the Lakers as your final act it at least
gives you a different argument for
Michael Jordan you know to put him in
you know because he'll never reach Mike
with six titles and no losses in the
finals but if he does do something like
this with the Lakers he's giving you a
different element to add to your
argument but let me just ask you this
and why can't he just be the greatest
player of his generation why can't we
just be happy with that we're never
happy with that why can't we be happy
with and the thing about LeBron is that
he will he will fit in an appeal on so
many levels he'll work perfectly in LA
because if you know who sits around that
court if you look at the people who sit
around that ring those are the titans of
the industry
and they when they come in you can make
a deal drawer warm-ups you know he can
he can be like hey hey Joseph I need you
to green light this movie we're gonna do
okay I got so-and-so so-and-so LeBron
done swing by you know the office
tomorrow we'll get this done I mean it
will change the way that entertainment
business is done and all his guys you
know maverick Carter those guys will all
sit on the bass line and it'll be
amazing it'll be a perfect act and we
will get to see brawny grow up and do
his thing right out here now Ronnie yeah
Bharani
I'm excited listen I'm excited for
LeBron to get here I mean I listen if
anybody doesn't think that this year is
gonna be a rough ride for the Lakers if
they think that Alonzo on his own is
gonna lift the team up then you you
clearly don't understand that you need
somebody to get the ball there is at
least buzz though Kevin that's what you
want you want to be relevant and
obviously didn't see the first Precinct
did you see it against Denver okay I
just seen anything in the preseason this
isn't like everybody I love when people
get excited about the summer league
it's the somebody ever used to watch the
summer league no and it's because
there's really nothing else on and if
your hoops head you watch the summer
league you're like oh he was killing he
was killing guys we're gonna play in
Poland next year and that's the thing
you have to remember I mean it's a
difference when you have to go to the
hole and they're like there are real
players it's a difference when you line
up against other guys who are like
all-stars it's don't sleep on pulling on
me don't sleep on I'm sorry I wish
basketball I mean that's not Turkey the
guys are playing in Turkey next year but
that's all he's Kevin Frazier
Entertainment Tonight you brought the
noise good luck to your team we
appreciate him stomping but we didn't
talk about the Kardashians you love to
talk Kardashians all the things you love
to talk about we didn't even get to a
Tristan Thompson get out of the sunken
place get out of the sunken place bro
Willie McGinest the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience